success happens to you not because you
design it because you own it you need to
earn success I have always believed that
success is a challenge to attain and it
is fleeting
once you have attained it rise and shine
it's an espresso time good morning
believe nation its Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside to you
that I want to see exploded onto the
world so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message earn success over to you
Sadhguru various situations in your life
either you can use it to make yourself
stronger and better or you can sit and
cry this is the choice you have and
everything it doesn't matter what
happens the most horrific event happened
in your life that also can be used for
your growth and your well-being if only
if you have clearly seen the small
events of your life when I say small
events I mean your business your
marriage your children all those big
things all these things are just a
stepping stone the fear of failure
failure is bad enough fear is adding
spice to it isn't it
success happens to you not because you
desire it because you earn it everybody
deserves it it comes only if you're
capable of it success happens not
because you desire it but because you
earn it I love that line I love it so
much
I've been featuring sadguru I think at
least once a month for the past couple
month and the ins Presto's because quite
often he says something that makes me
think a little differently and I don't
necessarily agree with and so I like
that a little bit of conflict to be able
to bring different perspectives to you
guys and for a second just a side note
on this video I thought he said
everybody deserves success but in the
replay I'm pretty sure he says everybody
desire success and so I really
fundamentally agree with him on this
video back to the point I think it's so
true that you have to earn success I
think so often we're caught up and
looking how other people may have been
given it to them may have more
opportunities in you yes maybe they have
a rich mother who funds their entire
dream yes maybe somebody is born in a
better country than you yes maybe
somebody has more education or has
inherited wealth like yes all those
things are real but so what you can
still go and get yours
there are tons of people who had less
than what you currently have right now
and have gone on and done amazing
amazing things and so what's your Excuse
you are where you are right now because
of you period except that when you
accept that and stop blaming other
people that's when your life starts to
change like you might feel really badly
like that's all on me that really sucks
but it's also empowering because now you
know you have the tools to be able to
Guelph and change it you are where you
are because of you and you're gonna be
where you're gonna be because of you -
not because of anybody else you earn
your success and for all the people who
just look at others who say well they're
lucky because they they were born into
well look at the three generation rule
there was a great study done I think
Forbes talked about in a bunch of other
publications for families that have had
money by the second generation seventy
percent of that wealth is gone and by
the third generation ninety percent of
that wealth is gone if you make multi
generational wealth chances are your
career get your grandkids are going to
spoil it all away because they didn't
earn it because they don't know what to
do with it
90% after three generations the money is
gone
you need to earn success and so I try to
surround myself with the stories of
people who've come from nothing
whether it's Oprah whether it's Elon Moz
I call these people who've started with
very little resources and we're able to
build something fantastically amazing
that inspires me because when I look at
their stories I think what did they have
that I don't have right now
if anything I'm spoiled if anything I'm
soft I don't have any excuses whatever
things that I say are holding me back
someone like Oprah someone like Sadhguru
someone like Priyanka Chopra had it a
thousand times on top of them and so
adopting that philosophy of extreme
ownership that I am where I am because
of me and I am going to be where I'm
going to be because of me to that I will
earn my success and it's nobody else's
fault or responsibility to give it to me
when you really own that that's when
things start to fly for you
now I have a special bonus clip for you
but before getting to it my question of
the day is I'm curious what are you most
proud of what's a success that you feel
you earned and you put tons of work into
it and you got that success what are you
most proud of so far in your business or
in your personal life leave in the
comments below I'm really curious and
I'd love to celebrate alongside you
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of an espresso
and enjoy the bonus
they spray so give me go
I have always believed that success is a
challenge to attain and it is fleeting
once you have attained it success is
challenging to get fleeting once you've
attained it I think you should never
take it for granted never should you
take success for granted mediocrity is
the norm I really really believe that
and if you guys look at how I run our
esteem
I mean don't listen to my words look at
my behavior every week I've got my new
content up every week I've got the new
stuff I'm focused on I've got new
projects on the go on put them banging
it out I view it like a privilege that I
get to teach pickup as a career that's a
privilege now most of you guys probably
think my life is like a joke because you
guys think that I'm like picking up hoes
teaching it bragging about it online
that's probably what it looks like right
I get it I would think that too and
that's a small element of it that's the
best part
but no I work my ass off addition a lot
of people say why do you still go out
for two you know usually seven nights a
week after 11 years why do you guys
think I go out seven nights a week after
11 years because I appreciate that I'm
in the position I'm in you know I say
it's a privilege I've got a big audience
here to listen to what I have to say
about live success with women's success
I take that very seriously and I think
that that success is something that is
earned and re-earn I think that in life
you're climbing up that mountain and you
want to take breaks strategically but
people think that you can climb up a
mountain and just kind of stay there not
really I view it like it's like a muddy
Mountain you climb up and you stay there
you start to slide down and there's a
number of reasons why that happens I'll
talk about them today does that mean you
should never take a break no I'm gonna
take a little time off when I do my
Miami events this year I'm gonna sit
there eating sushi in South Beach and
stare at my belly button and I'm it's
gonna be great
okay and I've got I'm looking forward to
going out to the islands in Hawaii this
summer and that's the long ways off when
I'm suffering
hard with a workload that's something I
can look forward to and I'm gonna sit
beside a waterfall and I'm gonna sit
there couldn't bol sing while my body
flushes the years where the court is all
out of it that's basically what I do
cool you know of course I believe in
taking a break I think you should spend
time with friends and take breaks but I
also believe that success is something
that has to be earned and re-earn the
world is a dynamic place the world is
changing if you're not changing along
with it you're probably being left
behind headlining download in in England
with with Slipknot in in 2009 that was
probably and I mean we've played we'd
played you know Rock and Rio before you
know I mean we'd played for big
audiences but that was huge for us you
know I mean with it you're talking about
essentially you know Donington you know
a festival that we had all grown up
reading about you know in hit Parader in
rip you know I mean just in these
magazines that really was our only
lifeline for hard rock and heavy metal
in Iowa you know and it was kind of hit
or miss on MTV so you kind of had to get
it where you could so reading about that
festival and then 2000 call it 20 years
later stepping on that stage and
headlining it was I still to this day I
choked up thinking about it because it
was such a statement you know it took us
10 years I mean we probably could have
headlined it any time you know 5 years
before that but it just wasn't the time
and when we stepped on that stage it was
huge and I can remember just looking at
the guys before we went on stage and
being like that we earned this nobody
gave this to us you know this is no
flash in the pan this is no you know can
you know consolation prize this was
every inch of sweat and blood and scar
tissue and every show we've ever played
in every minute we spent you know making
these fans happy that was huge for us
raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
with passion can change the world not
one drop of myself work depends on your
acceptance of me I don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
most a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual Clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details